let's talk about your show America's
most musical family are you guys ready
[Music]
hosting the show it's it's a cool
opportunity to kind of help push that
new generation of musicians for is it
crazy on the show when the little kids
look at you and they're like my mom the
young kids like my mom I was like oh
yeah yeah back in the day you know your
dad and I made out to their song
okay Nick I want to show you this
because I mean it's America's most
musical family that you've been with
your brother Drew the whole time let me
take you back I'm a little nervous but
hopefully I'll be able to calm down by
the time we have to go up on stage but I
think we're just here to have a good
time try to try to catch up with some
people we met before I meet some new
people's what a little hoop earrings
I've seen that wow that was a long time
ago all right it's the Christmas season
is there a Christmas Carol or Christmas
song that you guys love this thing in
the house they have to say it cuz my
wife makes him say it but you know they
always request the 90 degrees Christmas
not one not one but two Christmas albums
yeah Kevin I'm sure you have them both
in your collection the kids are
definitely all about hearing daddy's
saying but give us a little 98 degrees
Christmas come on I've been waiting to
give this give two nights ago I will
kill the harvest
[Music]